well I wasn't surprised in the way that
he's a great Adventurer going up to
going up high as high as he can get to a
little space even and when he did go on
for 10 minutes last year with other
people not the only man or person
um and so to me it wasn't too much of a
surprise that there he is down near the
Titanic which is the I suppose one of
the most famous ships in the world it
was a great Adventurer he
um
um he as it satisfied in the way that
hopefully he might have completed or at
least he did complete what he did
if we think about it
this was just a sad disaster
perhaps in some ways waiting to happen
do you think he died doing something
that he liked definitely yes in the
family I know the family agrees that
yes